I guess we can start by asking you what
you learned about Megan squirrels while
you were filming this movie I literally
everything was a learning experience for
me I wasn't familiar at all with the
Marine Corps which was one of the
reasons why I was really excited to be a
part of this film even just the boot
camp aspect of it was so fascinating to
me and very intimidating you know we had
we had actual drill sergeants there in
those scenes with us and they were
terrifying things addition there they
were amazing I mean obviously it's a
movie so we're only doing little
snippets here and there of what they
actually go through but regardless it
was quite intimidating them and they
were just amazing with him amazing just
the elbow thing crawling along ah did we
do that no we did you know climbing the
wall we did push-ups um like having to
like carry each other across
I don't know lots of watch the movie and
you'll see often dangerous um well yeah
it was it was just it was really fun to
be honest it was it was a really those
are some of my favorite days of shooting
it looked it like it was fun on on that
set and you must have been so honored to
get the Marines approval not only for
the film itself but for their depiction
in this film it means you you did right
yeah I mean that was it is such a great
honor and that's really the most
important thing to us you know we want
everyone to love the movie and be moved
by it and inspired by it but to actually
have the Marines to be recognized by
people that have actually been through
it and family is that experience is just
there's nothing like that Megan was with
a hero of course if everyone goes
hearing that he didn't like you yeah but
that's one of the reasons why I think
she is mind yeah and a lot of not just
her dog as well you meet her for the
first time Kate and what's going through
your mind it's like you're in the
presence of I was quite nervous yeah I
was we had spoken on the phone and she
was so sweet
it but yeah I was nervous I mean when
you're playing somebody and you're
telling their story their life story you
you want them to be proud of it and to
be happy with who is actually playing
them so I was I was nervous but she
instantly you know set me at ease and
and we felt like we knew each other it
was just like an instant sort of
connection yeah so I I really always
felt her support
she had this life-altering path they
switched on her and in the middle of her
life have you experienced a life
altering switch you know you're going
down one road and all of a sudden you're
going down a different road have you
experienced some time well I mean I've
had a very different experience I mean I
I I think I was lucky as a child I knew
I what I wanted to do in in my work life
anyway and I've never gone off that path
and it's still just as strong now as it
was when I was nine but I did actually
when I when I actually saw the
documentary blackfish
which our director Gabriella's directed
as well it I instantly knew like I need
to do more with animals and outside of
my career I need to do more to help in
ways that I feel strongly about and so
ever since then I've been working very
very intensely with the Humane Society
and a lot of different organizations but
specifically them and it's just brought
another level of passion to my life and
purpose and you know it's just as
important to me as my career is so I
relate in that way where all of a sudden
you wake up one day and you go oh my
gosh this is actually one of the reasons
why I'm here
excellent these animals these pets are
like family yeah as you know can you
talk about your relationship do you have
a pet you have I do I've got two dogs at
their Boston Terriers so they're much
smaller than then Rex was so that was an
interesting thing because obviously you
know a
an animal is an animal and they're all
loving and and so that's not different
but having to sort of fuel in control of
this of this dog was a very different
thing for me because my dogs weigh about
18 pounds and this dog weighs as much as
I do so it was it was intimidating at
first but once you form that bond it's
quite unbreakable have to ask you about
mercy before I leave here with our
girlfriend Alan page was it easy to fall
in love with her on set Oh Alan's the
most lovable human being on the planet
yeah I love Ellen Page she is one of my
closest friends and I you know we wanted
to work together for a bit and and we
found this very intense beautiful love
story and hopefully we'll have more
information on when it'll come out soon
you produce it yeah we produce it
together yeah that's amazing last
question will be house of cards you are
famously you know the aspect fairly look
at the same goes he went that way
right show it this way right yeah do you
still watch it are you interested in
attributes I love the show actually when
I once I wasn't on it I it was kind of
easier to watch you know it's nicer when
you're not on something to enjoy it you
judge it less yeah but I have to catch
up I die behind one season so and it's
true it's so true that we are living
this Frank Underworld Underwood world
with with President Trump right now do
you get all kind of erases fault yes
Evelyn Kevin's yeah I blame him